in this laboratory in yangming xiaotong
University near taiwan's Tech Hub in
sintu students are learning about a
semiconductor technology
dick Chang is taking his PhD in hopes to
be part of the world's largest
semiconductor industry
they want semiconductor industry has
become so huge in recent years the
Taiwanese government has invested a lot
of resources in it as well as in schools
throughout the pandemic Taiwan
semiconductor sector maintained its lead
but it is now in the crosshairs of a
geopolitical power play between the
United States and China
if the products or the technology
contain you know contain U.S technology
though it's Taiwanese company and its
Taiwanese products and made here and you
have to follow the U.S U.S rules
the U.S has restricted the export of
semiconductor materials to China to
prevent it from being able to make
advanced microchips Taiwan has followed
suit now local companies have no choice
but to adapt
companies they have to find their own
way out okay otherwise they cannot
survive in the markets so they have to
follow the global chain
and at the center of it all is one
company
tsmc produces more than half of the
world's microchips
tsmc is set to open a plant in Arizona
next year now one of the concerns is
that its biggest client Apple the
company that makes your iPhones could be
buying chips out of this U.S facility
and taking along with it parts of the
supply chain here in Taiwan which in
turn could take a huge chunk of the
Island's Tech Revenue away
adding to taiwan's worries China's
import ban on Taiwanese Goods in 2021 it
was pineapples ninety percent of which
were sold to China
the following year Beijing blocked the
shipment of fish a day after former U.S
House speaker Nancy Pelosi visited
Taiwan it's getting more and more
measures and also targeting variety of
different products but unless China
stops buying Taiwanese semiconductors
analysts say the economic impact is
manageable Beijing is also likely to
think twice about attacking Taiwan they
say because semiconductors run modern
devices which are essential to Modern
Life including in China
button below Al Jazeera scene 2 Taiwan